so you're not going to solve it with
this incredibly costly and very very
ineffective policy the way you're going
to solve it is like we've solved all of
the problems through Innovation remember
back in the 1950s Los Angeles was a
terribly polluted place
it was mostly because of cars and a
geological you know it put in a basin
and stuff but fundamentally the point
was not to tell everyone in Los Angeles
I'm sorry could you walk instead which
would never have worked right if they do
not walk in L.A no you're not going to
take people's cars away the solution was
this you know tiny technological Advance
called the catalytic converter and
innovator in 1978 you pluck it on the
end tailpipe and then you can drive much
longer and pollute much less yeah it
costs a couple hundred dollars but
you've actually managed to convince
almost everyone across the world this is
a good idea and it solved a very large
portion of the problem likewise the U.S
is the country that's caught most
emissions uh CO2 emissions over the last
10 years how not because of Obama or
Trump but because of fracking you
basically inadvertently made gas so much
cheaper that most people switched from
coal to gas and gas emits about half as
much CO2 as coal so you solved a large
part of the climate problem
through Innovation that's how we do it
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
the president of the Copenhagen
consensus and author of best things
first the 12 most efficient solutions
for the world's poorest and our Global
sdg promises Bjorn Lumberg welcome back
to the Reuben report hey it's great to
be here Bjorn and I checked right before
we started it's been over two years
which is absolutely crazy since the last
time that we spoke I don't know how that
happened but I do know that in these two
years the climate people the
catastrophization people have all
increasingly gone crazier but before we
dissect them for the for the people that
may not know you can you give me a one
minute bio on what gets you to doing all
the things you're doing and writing a
book like this and then we'll take it
from there sure uh what I focus on is
really to say look we don't have
unlimited funds we have limited
resources but there's so many things
we'd like to do why don't we focus on
where we can spend money and do the most
good first that's both true for climate
so let's do the SMART stuff and not the
stupid stuff on climate but it's also
true for all the other worlds problems
remember we promised you know to fix
hunger and poverty and education and all
the other problems in the world and what
this book really does is try to say
there are some amazingly smart policies
that we can do let's do those first
whatever else you'd love to do let's
spend money on that but let's just get
the was you know it's about 35 billion
dollars globally uh and and make the
world an impressively much better place
right so basically I mean the thesis of
the book you think for about 35 billion
we can fix pretty much the major stuff I
assume by your background there that you
think some of this includes just some uh
some plants you could probably get at
Home Depot just to keep the air in your
house clean huh wait please give me more
plants yeah no uh so we're not going to
fix all problems but we're going to fix
a majority of problems and what we're
essentially uh showing is and we worked
with more than 100 world's top
economists and several Nobel laureates
to try to find out what do we already
know works and what we find is for 35
billion dollars a year that's not
nothing I mean I don't think you have I
certainly don't have it but yeah you're
doing all right but that might be
pushing it yes but in the global setting
of things that is really couch change
for 35 billion dollars a year we could
save 4.2 million people from dying each
and every year and we could make the
poor half of the world about 1.1
trillion dollars better off this is
probably the very best thing we could do
for the world and that's why I'm saying
let's at least do those best things
first and that's also why you're a bit
of a controversial character because
you're trying to give solutions that are
different than what seem to be the
solutions given to us by say the wef and
the UN and much of our Western
governments and and all that so I want
to spend most of this conversation
talking about those Solutions but I
thought why don't we get some of the
people and organizations out of the way
that are causing the problems like when
you see the wef and the 2030 project all
of these things the the green new deal
here in America all of these giant
expenditures that will massively change
things do you look at them all as sort
of these are just complete nonsensical
boondoggle pipe dreams that will never
work like is there anything good and is
there any good nugget in any of these
things well first of all there's the
amazing good that actually shows that a
lot of people want to do good they
really want to be part of something that
makes the world better now there is a
real problem with many of the things
they identify but very often it ends up
being a very ineffective way to try to
tackle the problem you know take heat
waves which is in in the in the
conversation right now yes we're going
to see more heat wave because of climate
change and climate change is a real
problem but we need to get a sense of
proportion first of all remember many
many more people die from cold and from
heat and so we also need to remember to
actually help all the people who suffer
from cold which is mostly about getting
them cheap energy access but also if you
want to help the people who are
suffering from more heat and we should
it's mostly about getting sure people
access to air conditioning it's about
having them get cheap electricity and of
course also make cities more livable one
of the ways you could do that is by
making Greener making more water
features making them lighter uh Los
Angeles and many other cities have you
know experimenting with painting the
rooftops white or a painting of the
tarmac white and that reflects a lot of
the energy away and actually makes these
cities much cooler the point here is
those sorts of
will actually help right now at very low
cost and help real people where as much
of the argument that you have with these
you know we should all go Net Zero we'll
have huge costs we're talking five ten
trillion dollars this is more than what
most countries spend on education or
even health care and even if you did it
it would only mean that temperatures
would rise but not quite as much that's
no way to help people so my point here
is to say let's focus on the smart
solution that'll actually help right and
I think one of the problems is as I
often play clips of these people the the
elites who seem to be pushing A lot of
these policies and you know they don't
want you to have your stove and they're
you know they don't want you to have
this hot water heater or whatever it
might be we know they're on their
private jets and all of these things and
by the way I don't begrudge them any of
those things except for the fact that
they're trying to make sure none of us
get those luxury items but when you say
uh and I quote climate change is real I
know a certain amount of my audience is
going to go wait a minute we've just had
it even hearing that because because
they're so upset by hearing John Kerry
and they're so upset by watching
Leonardo DiCaprio act one way on his
yacht and helicopter and then preach
another way so when you say climate
change is real what do you actually mean
by that meaning that that obviously the
climate is changing but do you mean
man-made and and how much of that is
something that we can actually affect
so again I work with economists so we're
looking at what are the smart Solutions
I have read unlike I think a lot of
people uh almost all I don't advise
anyone to do that it's very very boring
but all of the U.N climate panel reports
and they're reasonably sensible all the
way through they're really trying to
tell you what is the best uh uh
scientific evidence and the the short
version is we're pumping out more CO2
from Mostly from fossil fuels CO2 is one
of the many greenhouse gases that trap
heat and make the world a little bit
warmer this all other things
problems then it's going to make
Solutions simply because we built our
entire entire Society on what the
temperature was was the last 100 200
years if it got colder or if it gets
warmer which is probably going to be
because of global warming that will
incur a cost this is not the end of the
world as it's being uh you know sold it
is a problem so economists and the only
climate Economist to win the Nobel Prize
William nordhaus estimate that by the
end of the century if we do nothing
which is stupid and we shouldn't do it
probably is impossible but even if we
did nothing the cost by the end of the
century would be equivalent to losing
that four percent of our GDP now
remember by then we'll be much richer
the U.N estimate will be about 450
percent richer as rich as we are today
so what this really means is because of
global warming if we do nothing it will
feel like we'll only be 434 percent as
Rich by the end of the century rather
than 450. that's not the end of the
world that's a problem and that's why
I'm saying look if it's the end of the
world of course you should spend every
thing to fix it but that's not what this
is it's a problem and we should spend
money smartly on this problem but also
remember there are lots of other
problems that are much bigger for most
people so before we get to some of those
specific 12 Solutions what would you say
to the people who are just sort of
skeptical that we can do anything about
this meaning like so for an America from
an American perspective for example that
we're so sort of inefficient our
politics is so broken these people can't
build a road much properly or at least
that cost you know in a cost-effective
way that the idea that they could solve
any of these things is completely crazy
and then you hear people like AOC say
you know we only have 12 years left on
Earth I think that was about three years
ago so now we've got nine and it's like
if you think AOC can solve any of your
problems much less solve climate
problems you know I got a bridge to sell
you so I I think a lot of the intuition
is right that we are essentially
embarking in something that's going to
be so phenomenally costly that most
countries are actually not going to
deliver on this I I live in the EU I
actually worry a little bit the EU is so
good at doing stuff they promised that
we might actually do it despite the fact
that it's going to be phenomenally
costly but certainly in the U.S and most
other places you'll simply elect how the
politicians want to really start hurting
that's how Paul you know how democracies
work and that's probably really good so
you're not going to solve it with this
incredibly costly and very very
ineffective policy the way you're going
to solve it is like we've solved all
other problems through Innovation
remember back in the 1950s Los Angeles
was a terribly polluted place
it was mostly because of cars and a
geological you know it put in a basin
and stuff but fundamentally the point
was not to tell everyone in Los Angeles
I'm sorry could you walk instead which
would never have worked right if they do
not walk in L.A no you're not going to
take people's cars away the solution was
this you know tiny technological Advance
called the catalytic converter and
Innovative in 1978 you plug it on the
end tailpipe and then you can drive much
longer and pollute much less yeah it
costs a couple hundred dollars but
you've actually managed to convince
almost everyone across the world this is
a good idea and it solved a very large
portion of the problem likewise the U.S
is the country that's caught most
emissions uh CO2 emissions over the last
10 years how not because of Obama or
Trump but because of fracking you
basically inadvertently made gas so much
cheaper that most people switched from
coal to gas and gas emits about half as
much CO2 as coal so you solved a large
part of the climate problem
through Innovation that's how we do it
remember if we can innovate green energy
to be cheaper than fossil fuels everyone
will switch Rich well-meaning Americans
or Europeans but also the Chinese the
Indians and the Africans who are going
to be emitting most of the CO2 in this
Century so I totally get your and your
your viewers of you know sort of
reluctance we are trying to solve this
very ineffectively and Incredibly
expensively which probably means we
won't solve it at all
there is a smart way and it's coal
Innovation
that's exactly why I wanted to have you
on because I know even for me in the
last year especially as I've watched so
many of these globalist organizations
with these crazy projects and then the
hypocrisy and literally the gas stove
thing here in America all of this
nonsense even I have become more
skeptical in a way that I don't I don't
want to be blindly skeptical I want to
be skeptical with with some knowledge of
what's going on which is exactly why we
have you on so let's let's talk about
some of those Solutions uh because you
lay out these 12 Solutions so give me
give me some what's like the easiest
thing that we can start doing now
probably some of which we're doing to
some degree
so I'll I'll tell you too uh you know
it's asking I have 12 great Solutions
you're asking me to pick my favorite
childhood but yeah uh I am going to give
you two one is uh to save lives so one
thing that I think most people don't
recognize is that each year
tuberculosis still kills 1.41.5 million
people last year it was bigger again
than covet you know covet took the the
top place for infectious disease killer
in 2020 and 21 but other
go but if you actually go back
tuberculosis was a terrible killer this
is why you know Sabine and uh Moulin
Rouge died from tuberculosis and
fourth of everyone who lived in the
1800s in in Europe in the U.S died from
tuberculosis this was a a terrible
killer it killed probably about a
billion people over the last 200 years
but we figured out a way to do it now we
don't have a problem but most poor
countries is not that place and there's
a very simple way it's unfortunately one
of the reasons why it's hard to do you
actually have to take your medication
for half a year and most people know
that it's hard to just take your
medication for two weeks but there's a
lot of ways to you know sort of gamify
it get sort of tuberculosis Anonymous
where everybody gets together once in a
month and say yes I took my my
medication all the way through and you
know you gamified and give people a
carton of orange juice that kind of
thing and it may seem a little weird
that you have to pay people to do it but
if you do that if you make sure that
they don't have tuberculosis they don't
pass it on to another 10 to 20 people
and this is how we solve much of the
problem you also need to screen many
more people we've investigated and
there's lots of modeling show how much
is this going to cost it's probably
going to cost about 6
billion dollars a year so again not
nothing but we can save almost a million
people from dying over the next half
century every year so this is one of the
things where we say and we we're you
know we're we're slightly crude
economists we go in and say how much
will it cost and how much good will it
do so we give you a benefit cost ratio
we try to estimate for every dollar
spent how much good will you end up
doing turns out if you do on
tuberculosis for every dollar spent
you'll do 46 dollars of social good
that's just an incredible opportunity so
do you guys bring these ideas to say a
guy like Bill Gates who's got the
billions who who seemingly wants to help
you know by his own words would say he
wants to help the people of Africa and
help the world do you bring these ideas
to them and then and then what do they
say yes and we both talked to Bill Gates
actually The Gates Foundation paid for
this project uh but we we talked to Bill
Gates I wrote a an ABBA together with
him uh we talked to usaid and other
organizations but crucially we also talk
to a lot of poor country government
moments who obviously should also Pony
up some of this money because it's their
own citizens who are dying and much of
this is they're dying because they're
not the you know they're not the rich
people in the poor part of the world if
you're rich in in the poor part of the
world you don't get tuberculosis and
even if you do you don't die from it but
you know the slum populations is the
migrant populations it's the miners it's
the prison populations but the problem
is this percolate all the way through
societies so we try to take all of these
arguments and make people aware that
here's a very cheap way to make the
world much much better and yes they say
oh that's really interesting now they're
not going to say oh sure so here are six
billion dollars make it make it a way of
your first of all that's not what I do
I'm an academic grad I wouldn't know
what to do with it and there's a lot of
organizations are actually really good
at this so you should it to your
National
Health Care Systems and the you know
stop tpe campaign and many others in
those countries but the point is we're
trying to make it easier for politicians
and for philanthropists and for
development organizations to spend right
to spend it where it really matters so
all right before we get to that second
one that that you like out of these 12
and then we'll get to as many as
possible how do you make sure that the
mechanisms are in place that these
things just don't become what seemingly
most government Things become which are
giant you know government waste projects
we don't you know we give money to
everybody we never get receipts on
anything I think that that's another
thing that a lot of people are worried
about these days like even if you can
convince them of of some of the risks
and why we can do some good things here
they're just like ah you know we're just
going to pour money and maybe it'll work
maybe it won't but we just won't know
very correct uh uh concern and a lot of
the thing
the thing go to things that make you
feel good uh things that look good on TV
uh but have very little effect but we're
actually using the best models of things
have already been done where we showcase
look if you spend the money here even
though someone is going to go to waste
that you know that's
probably true almost everywhere in the
world and some of it was just going to
be spent incompetently that's just the
way the world Works we've taken that
into our calculation so we're not
assuming that this is going to be
heroically spent in the very best
possible way it's going to be spent
reasonably come competently like you
know you would actually hope you can
reasonably do this and let me let me
share this because it's much clearer
within with the other uh proposal I was
going to talk about namely education
education is something everyone agrees
both sucks and we should do much more
about right it especially sucks in the
poor part of the world uh so there's
almost half a billion kids in Primary
School in in the poor part of the world
we got almost all kids in school that's
great but they're learning virtually
nothing we say that they technically
learn to read but if you ask them this
question so you ask them to read this
question this is a 10 year old right
Vijay has a red hat blue shirt and
yellow shoes what color is the Hat
it's red right but 80 I got it I got it
thank you thank you so you're there 80
of kids cannot answer this question and
it's not because they're dumb it's
because they can't actually string all
these words together into a meaningful
sentence and of course that means we've
technically taught them to read but they
can't actually use it to become more
productive and become richer and more
resilient I'll do all the wonderful
things
it's it is it's that they haven't
actually learned most of the stuff so
what we find is you should spend more
money on education but this is exactly
where you would say oh but there's a lot
of ways you can spend it badly and
that's absolutely true so one example
that I give in the book is Indonesia and
you know you know bless their hearts
they really want to do good they
care so much about education that we're
going to double spending on education so
they ended up hiring more than a million
new teachers they doubled the uh pay for
each of these teachers and because of
the way they did it so they did it in
different regions at different times
there's actually a big study that could
sort of look this as a pseudo-random
trial where you could see well how much
good does this actually do for the
schools and it turns out this famous
paper is called double for nothing and
it basically shows yes you spent twice
as much money and there was no impact
whatsoever on teaching it's very very
easy to spend money badly on education
and this is true everywhere else but
what we identify are three great ways
that are very very well tested I'm just
going to tell you one of them so the
problem in most schools but especially
in poor countries is you have 50 kids in
this one you know in this fourth grade
they're all 12 years old but they have
wildly different abilities you know some
of them are far ahead of the teacher
some of the virtually no clue what's
going on and what's a teacher going to
do he's going to try to teach somewhere
in the middle and you know some kids are
going to be bored lots of kids are going
to be totally lost he should teach each
one of these kids at his or her own
level but of course you can't do that if
you have 50 kids but if you put each of
these kids in front of a tablet with
educational software just one hour a day
this tablet would be actually the
software will very quickly figure out
where exactly are you on this you know
are you really ahead of this curve or
not and teach you at your exact level so
the rest of the school will still be
this boring old school where most kids
will be lost or bored but one hour a day
they'll actually learn and what it turns
out and there's lots of evidence that
for twenty one dollars a year per
student they're not going to get the
tablet it's going to be shared with a
lot of other kids and all that stuff and
you also need you know solar panels and
places where they don't have electricity
you need a locker for the uh for the
tablet so they don't don't get stolen
all this but it actually turns out that
for every year they go to school they
will now learn three years of schooling
it's still pretty bad schooling so it's
not like phenomenal they're not going to
be Einsteins just from this but this is
a way that we can actually make almost
half a billion billion kids
smarter and what that means is that they
will when they become adults go out and
be much more productive actually make
their Nations much richer and of course
that will solve a lot of the other
problems they have so we estimate this
will cost globally about 10 billion up
so again not nothing but it will
actually generate benefits worth 600
billion dollars each and every year this
is just amazing and astounding so
instead of spending it badly we should
spend it on this really really effective
way you know it's funny I'm reminded of
a Simpsons episode from probably around
1993 where Bart is struggling in school
so they put him in the slower class and
then he looks at the teacher in the
slower class and goes let me get this
straight I'm struggling in the other
class so now you've made me put me in a
slower class how does this make any
sense to you people say you're trying to
solve that okay so it seems like between
education and tuberculosis if I'm if my
math is correct we're at about 16
billion which is about half of uh what
you need to fix some of the problems so
we've got about eight or nine minutes
left let's let's plow through a couple
others to let's get to that 32.
tell you one other so one that I think
uh amazed me is the fact that maternity
and especially pregnancy and especially
birth is terribly dangerous uh so it
turns out about 300 000 moms die each
year around pregnancy and about 2.3
million kids die in the first 28 days in
their life on Earth and this is not
Rhymes how we deal with us this
this facility so about two-thirds of
them give birth in facilities we need to
get like 90 percent of them into
facilities and these facilities need to
have basic emergency obstetric care this
is something the World Health
Organization lots of Institutions have
shown what will that take you know it's
about having I don't know disinfectant
uh you'd imagine that would be sort of
obvious but actually a lot of them don't
have a clean water so that you can wash
down the surfaces but it's also
something so simple as it turns out that
about 700
000 kids each year die because they
never start breathing so they come out
they get you know they're given birth
but then they don't start breathing now
this also happened in rich countries so
about 80 percent of all kids that come
out of the mom you know just start
breathing right away 15 need this slap
in the back uh to get going but the last
five percent don't and you know in the
rich world of course we just simply put
a mask over their mouth and put positive
air pressure put it into the lungs and
they go and then they go and then we
save them but we don't have that in
about half of all the poor parts of the
world this is a this this hand call
Sport 75 dollars and it could probably
save 25 lives over its three-year life
period that's the kind of thing so
there's a whole list of things this will
cost about five billion dollars again uh
so but it will save 166
000 moms from dying each and every year
and it will save 1.2 million kids each
and every year how are we not doing that
so yeah
actually every dollar spent will deliver
87 worth of good so there's malaria yeah
you've got me to I see about 21 million
so far we're getting there so
I'm telling you the sort of uh more
expensive stuff first because
really big things malaria is actually a
huge but it used to be a huge problem
around the world and no longer it's just
in Africa there's a lot of reasons for
that but we know how to fix it it's
simply giving out uh more of these uh uh
insecticide treated bad meds so people
will sleep under these nets they both
physically make sure that the mosquitoes
can't come in and bite you and it also
kills them off because as insects aside
it is very effective very simple
treatment it'll cost about 1.1 billion
dollars a year and it will save about
300 000 people each and every year again
a fantastic investment one other thing
that I think you'll find incredibly
interesting is agricultural research and
development so you know we worry about
the fact that people don't have enough
food we also have uh part I'm not going
to tell you about that we also talk
about how we can get better food to kids
but it turns out a lot of that is very
uh uh corruption prone right if you
spend a lot of money on on food a lot of
people we see that for instance in India
a lot of Merchants will sell you really
bad food and then you try to generate it
from for free and nobody really wants it
because it tastes terrible kind of thing
so the best way to deal with this is to
just like we talked about before with
climate innovation
we've had a Green Revolution back in the
60s and 70s which basically meant that
we could produce maybe twice as much
food on the same acre of land which is a
great Innovation you just simply make
the seed much more productive we need
that for all the stuff they grow in the
poor part of the world so that sorcum
and kasawa and all these things that you
probably haven't heard of but we need
the same Green Revolution there we
estimate this would cost about 5.5
billion dollars a year but it would
generate much more food but that would
both means the price would be lower for
people who live in the cities but it
would mean that the farmers could
produce much more so the farmers would
also get richer everyone would win and
we'd avoid about 100 million people uh
starving each and every year going on
that for a moment how much tension do
you see between big cities and rural
areas these days you know I I was in
Cali before where there was always this
incredible tension between say Los
Angeles where I was obviously you have
you know eight million people something
like that in a relatively small area
then you have the whole north of the
state which is all the agricultural land
they were always fighting for more water
the people of La wanted the water just
the general like day-to-day living of
who gets what oh absolutely and look
cities get a lot more money everywhere
because that's where you know the power
is that's where the politicians live
that's you know who runs the media and
everything else uh and and so in that
sense what we try to pick up is a lot of
the great Investments are in poorer
areas because that's where you can save
people really cheaply so one thing is
for instance more childhood immunization
uh and that's especially about so we've
got about 80 90 vaccinated most places
around the world you know measles for
instance great idea don't skimp under
your measles vaccination right it's it's
just a terribly deadly disease that used
to kill about 800 000 now we're down to
eighty thousand but you still need to
get more people vaccinated otherwise
you're going to get these epidemics
again and getting the last ones out in
the in in the sticks is going to be more
expensive but even then we find with a
much more expensive cost it's going to
cost about sorry I'm just looking at the
cost because I can't just remember those
1.7 billion dollars a year uh but it's
going to save about half a million kids
each and every year uh so the benefit
cost rate is about 101. uh so so again
we try to identify uh different things
that are incredibly good we simply said
we're going to identify the best buys
and we put the bar at 15 which is you
know somewhat arbitrary but as you know
some something our Nobles did uh uh just
simply for saying what these are the so
no-brainers that everybody should just
agree this is something we should be
doing how worried are you when when you
talk about vaccines now because of
everything that happened with covid you
know these bells go off in my head about
vaccines and how they get in people's
arms and the uh that the uh
pharmaceutical companies you know they
have no ability to be sued all of these
things that now people are skeptical of
things say a measles vaccine that really
very few people were skeptical of say
five years ago now you just say vaccine
and now it's setting off bells on people
that have long been dormant and and and
that's a terrible outcome and and the
the way I try to treat it is to talk
about childhood immunization we're not
talking about you know we should do
another uh covet vaccine which obviously
is hugely uh sort of uh divisive
divisive that's either way I'll go with
you yeah but but you know childhood
vaccines everyone know has just saved an
enormous amount of kids uh obviously uh
the the fact that we could vaccinate
against smallpox uh which you know just
last century actually kill somewhere
between 300 and 500 million people and
we have eradicated in 1978 there's no
more smallpox in the world this probably
every year saves what four or five
million people from dying that's just a
fantastic outcome this is true from
measles and many of these other simple
diseases this is not rocket science this
is something we know so we need to sort
of get over our uh ourselves and and our
worry about and and I think you know I I
see the correct conversation about to
what extent did we do right uh and the
priorities on on covet and that's for a
whole different kind of conversation but
we know that this works uh for childhood
immunization and that's what we're
arguing for
be wondering if my math is correct we
got to about 26 billion but
unfortunately we're out of time but I
will have you back on soon to continue
this discussion because I think it's
important to get between the skepticism
and the ability to do things
functionally that will actually make our
lives better that's what you're all
about we'll link to the book down below
and it was good to see you thank you
likewise if you want to find out
precisely when the world is going to end
check out our environment playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a wide variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell